Was tun, wenn man mal Trübsal bläst und anfängt hier zu schmollen? Was tun, wenn man mal schmunzeln will, lachen und sich freuen? Was tun, wenn man mal Trübsal bläst und anfängt hier zu schmollen? Was tun, wenn man mal schmunzeln will, lachen und sich freuen? Podcast-UFO ist doch klar, es lebt die Pufopedia, Stefan T und Florentin für Comedy der Hauptgewinn. Podcast-Ufo ist doch klar, es lebt die Pufopedia, die besten Witze weit und breit kommen in dir die Zeit. Was tun, um all die Angst und Not und Sorgen zu vergessen? Was tun, wenn alle böse sind und dich nur noch stressen? Was tun, um all die Angst und Not und Sorgen zu vergessen? Was tun, wenn alle böse sind und dich nur noch stressen? Podcastufo ist doch klar, es lebt die Pufopedia, Stefanie und Florentin für Comedy der Hauptgewinn. Podcastufo ist doch klar, es lebt die Pufopedia, die besten Witze weit und breit, komm nimm dir die Zeit.
Was tun, wenn man nicht schlafen kann und noch lange wacht, was tun, wenn man alleine ist in der dunklen Nacht, was tun, wenn man nicht schlafen kann und noch lange wacht, was tun, wenn man alleine ist in der dunklen Nacht?
Hey, Podcastufo ist doch klar, es lebt die Pufopedia, Stefan T und Florentin für Comedy der Hauptgewinn.
Podcastufo ist doch klar, es lebt die Pufopedia, die besten Wit wir sind richtig in Schwung gekommen. Vielen, vielen Dank für diesen fantastischen Intro-Song von Martin, der mal wieder das alte Genre des Shanty-Cores auf hat leben lassen. Finde ich richtig toll, gerade sehr modern, tatsächlich sehr beliebt. Durch dich TikTok wieder sehr beliebt. Wir sind am Zahn der Zeit. Ne, sagt man nicht so, ne? Wir sind offensichtlich, Leute, die den Begriff Zahn der Zeit benutzen, sind nicht am Zahn der Zeit. Sind definitiv nicht am Zahn der Zeit, ne. Ich habe das mal irgendwo, wurde ich dafür hart kritisiert, öffentlich angefeindet, weil ich das immer falsch benutze. Du hast immer so ganz... Ne, nicht der Zahn der Zeit. Es nagt der Zahn der Zeit, nein, man ist am Zahn der Zeit. Du hast ganz merkwürdige Shitstorms immer. Ganz merkwürdig. Bei anderen Leuten immer irgendwelche Skandale, bei dir immer, du hast ein Wort falsch betont und dann musst du dich drei Wochen aus der Öffentlichkeit ... Dann die große Kuh-Sache. Ich habe immer Qualle gesagt und nicht Qualle, das war der größte Shitstorm bis dato. Ich glaube, du konntest zwei Monate lang nicht auf die Straße gehen, komplett belagert von Paparocinis, überall nur ... Always pee before you leave, Florentin. Das ist die große Regel. Möchtest du mich jetzt hier in Frage stellen? Ja, weil du kommst hier rein und dann erst mal immer, ich bin noch mal kurz weg, was ja Code ist für, ich bin noch mal so im Klo, dann fangen wir in Ruhe an, alles ist gesettelt. Always pee before you leave, not the place you arrive at. Immer wenn man ankommt, hallo, schöne Wohnung, wo ist die Toilette? Auf gar keinen! Man will sofort klarmachen, wer der Chef ist. Du bist wie ein Hund, du willst erst mal direkt das Revier markieren. Richtig ist aber eigentlich zu sagen, das ist Larry Davids Regel, always pee before you leave. Wenn man geht, ich mach's immer falsch, ist aber eine Regel, wenn man sich darin hält, lebt man wirklich ein besseres Leben. Da, wo du zu Hause bist, kurz oder wo du aufbrichst und noch kurz aufs Klo gehen, dann woanders ankommen, mit frischen Augen nochmal die Welt und diesen neuen Ort, den du erklimmst.
Als introvertierter Mensch ist ohnehin in fremden Orten die Toilette dein wichtigster Zufluchtsrat.
Egal wenn du in einem Restaurant bist, Empfang, Hochzeit oder sowas, vor allem wenn die Toiletten unten sind.
Im Keller, du hast so eine ganze Welt für dich. Oben pocht die Musik
und du bist oben im Restaurant.
Auch ansprechendes Restaurant.
Und du machst die Tür zu.
Ja, und du bist für dich.
Ich glaube, Elektromusik wird auch so
komponiert, dass sie
möglichst gut durch eine Wand legt,
dass man sie im
Klo, während man Koks, schnüffelt.
Der schlimmste Moment ist immer ...
Da, da, da! Ja, wenn man rausgeht, aber dieses Moment, wenn du dir schon zu viel Zeit genommen hast auf dem Klo, Du hörst schon draußen
Hallo, Stefan! Hallo, Stefan! Hallo, Stefan! Hallo, Stefan! Hallo, Stefan! Hallollo Stefan, und dann hört man das schon und denkt, jetzt kann ich nicht so länger fehlen, wir würden sonst einfach autauen, wir würden sonst ein Taxi nehmen, merkt man, man war schon zu lange auf dem Klo und dann dieser Moment, wenn du die Tür aufmachst, und es ist schlimm, das ist das Schlimmste, wenn dir wieder wie so eine Welle, platzt dir die Musik ins Gesicht. Ja, du hast wieder so diesen Wodka-O-Geruch, der dir entgegenkommt. Ich war noch nie in dem Club, um ganz eng zu sein. Doch, du warst zuletzt 2006 im Club. Deine Referenzen nachzuurteilen warst du zuletzt bei der WM 2006. Ich schlittere einen eisigen Abhang herunter und ich kann mich nirgendwo festhalten gerade. Ich schlittere immer tiefer. Ich kann mich nicht festhalten. Du hast dich an Wodka-O festgehalten, was in etwa ist wie, du hast dich an nichts festgehalten. Nee, aber deswegen versuche ich immer, wenn ich irgendwo in fremden Orten bin, erstmal die Toilette auf meine Seite zu kriegen, zu wissen, wo ist sie, wo kann ich mich zurückziehen, wo ist sie, dann fühle ich mich direkt wohl. Ich bin auch beim Wodka-O, ist es mir leid, weil Wodka-O riecht ja, man trinkt das, dein Shitstorm kurz, man trinkt ja Wodka, also Alkoholiker trinken Wodka, damit Leute oder Kollegen nicht riechen, dass sie gerade was getrunken haben. Heißt, Wodka ist komplett geruchlos. Der Fakt, dass du gerade gesagt hast, oh, dann kommt einem dieser Wodka-O-Geruch entgegen, heisst Orangesaft. Es riecht toll. Stefan hat den Fall gelöst, ich bin ein Lügner, ich habe beim Leben noch nie in dem Club. Aber auf sehr vielen O-Saft-Plantagen. Ja, das auf jeden Fall. O-Saft-Plantagen. Wie viel Zeit spart man in seinem Leben insgesamt, wenn man O-Saft sagt statt Orangensaft? Also was machen Leute mit den Jahren an Lebenszeit, die sie sparen und am Ende ihres Lebens haben und sagen, ja, jetzt habe ich noch acht Jahre, wäre ich O-Saft gesagt. Erst mal schön Wodka-E-mischen, sagen die dann. Wodka-E,
Energy. Das E steht für Energy.
Ach so, ja.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es dies lohnt, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, hauptsächlich.
Du sagst ja, sagst du A-Saft dann auch?
Ja, aber Multivitaminsaft hat man sich beschlossen,
auszusprechen.
Die Zeit, die man bei Multivitaminsaft verwendet,
muss man wieder reinholen durch O-Saft,
damit man was Säfte anliegt auf Null kommt.
Aber das ist viel anstrengend geworden.
Warum sagt man da nicht M-Saft? Nein, Multivitaminsaft und O-Saft. Ja, ist merkwürdig. Es macht keinen Sinn. Der Multivitaminsaft weiß auch niemand, was da drin ist. Weiß wirklich niemand, was da drin ist. Und wie viele Früchte müssen drin sein, damit es ein Multivitaminsaft ist? Gute Frage. Es sind ja willkürliche Bilder abgebildet. Also ich rede zum Beispiel vom Durstlöscher oder von der Capri-Sonne. Capri-Sonne? Ja. Ich rede von hohes C, Multivitaminsaft, Mui. Ah, okay. Nee, dann reden wir komplett aneinander vorbei. Ja, gut, das ist ja nicht das erste Mal. Mui-Sar, könnte man auch sagen. Willst du das einführen? Nee, ehrlich gesagt. Kennst du das manchmal, wenn man so eine Frage gestellt bekommt und man ist noch nicht bereit, das einzuführen? Das Gefühl hatte ich gerade. Movieser. Man denkt so, ich will noch zwei, drei Monate drüber brainstormen und noch so ein bisschen die Ecken abschleifen. Gib mir noch zehn Minuten. Ich habe dann, ich habe ein neues Wort in der Schublade, aber ich will noch nicht drüber reden. Es ist noch unfertig und klar, hier und da auf Partys erzähle ich schon, übrigens, ich arbeite gerade an einem neuen Wort, aber können wir was sehen?
Nee, ist noch geheim.
Aber worum geht es denn grob, also in welche Richtung geht es denn grob?
Ja, es ist eine grob Getränkeindustrie, aber ist es noch geheim.
Ach, okay, für Cola oder was, Cola, Cola Light, dass man nicht immer Cola Light sagen muss, sondern einfach nur Light.
Okay, Thorsten, komm, ich sag's dir, wir sagen nicht mehr Multivitaminsaft, wir sagen Movisa. Oh. Ist auch gut, um aus unangenehmen Gesprächen rauszukommen, einfach immer so mit dem Fuss nach hinten so die Tür aufzumachen. Okay, alles ist los? Ist eigentlich ideal. Klo ist ideal, aber das ist wirklich die grössten, grossartigsten zwei Minuten der Clubzeit. Klo. Ja. Oder halt auch woanders. Im Restaurant finde ich immer ganz toll, weil ich finde ja immer, am Restaurant merkt man, wie gut das Restaurant ist. Weil da hast du dann zum Beispiel auch bei den richtig guten Restaurants kleine Handtücher. Du hast kleine Handtücher und musst nicht diese Papierverschwendungsschleuder anwerfen. Oder noch schlimmer, was ich hier ganz furchtbar finde, vor allem jetzt in Zeiten von Corona undenkbar, diese Schlaufe, wo du... Ja, aber ist es eine Schlaufe? Waschmaschine? Ich weiß es nicht. Aber diese Art, wo oben das wieder reinkommt und dann kommt es unten wieder raus, nie im Leben. Und was passiert dazwischen drin? Was passiert da drin in diesem Riesengebilde? Ja, ist da eine riesige Dampfmaschine drin, die da irgendwie dann so Dampf da durchpumpt oder was? Oder ist das wieder zu rein? Ja, ein Trockenmangel. Und es kommt auch gebügelt raus, gefühlt. Oder ist einfach gar nichts? Ich glaube, es ist gar nichts. Es ist so, der Zahn der Zeit vergeht quasi an dem Papier, nagt an dem Papier. Das muss ein Sprichwort sein. Und jedenfalls glaube ich, dass nie im Leben passiert darin ein so befriedigender Waschvorgang, dass unten normales Papier rauskommt, glaube ich einfach nicht. Heißt, das ist halt also auch gestorben
und gute Restaurants haben deswegen
kleine Handtücher. Dann nimmst du die, dann machst
du die in einen davor vorgegesehenen Bottich,
machst du die rein, dann werden die irgendwann gewaschen
alle. Kleine Handtücher. Wollte ich auch
bei mir zu Hause mal einführen, aber
wo kriegt man so viele kleine Handtücher her?
Da war ich anscheinend noch nie in einem so edlen Restaurant
regelmäßig, das habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Bei mir, ich habe bis jetzt verschiedene Konstrukte zur Handtrocknung gesehen und habe mich immer gedacht, ne, Hosentasche ist besser. Hosentasche ist besser als Handtrocknung. Ja, Hosentasche funktionieren einfach besser als das. Stimmt. Deswegen kommst du immer so cool, lässig aus den Klos raus. Ja, also richtig, hey, hallo Leute. Deswegen, wenn ich irgendwo eingeladen bin, auch erstmal direkt aufs Klo, damit ich von da nochmal einen Auftritt haben kann. Ja, das stimmt. Weil es ist ja manchmal schwer, irgendwie neu in Gespräche reinzukommen und irgendwie so sozusagen, jetzt habe ich mich richtig verrannt und dann nochmal einen neuen Auftritt. Der Auftritt aus dem Klo ist immer ein neuer Auftritt, dass du immer so zurückkommen kannst mit so einem grossen Einatmen und so einem tolle Handtücher. Ja, und du kannst den Opener überlegen. Erstmal, vielleicht bietet dir das Klo sogar selber so ein bisschen ein Thema, den nächsten Icebreaker.
Oder man hat zumindest die fünf Minuten am Klo noch Zeit, sich einen neuen Spruch zu überlegen.
Oh, wie geht es eigentlich deinem Bruder? Ist dein Bruder schon aus dem Krankenhaus zurück?
Nein.
Ist dein Bruder immer noch trocken?
Er hat im Krankenhaus wieder angefangen zu trinken.
Mist.
Schade. Entschuldige mich kurz, ich bin kurz am Klo. Dann hat man noch mal Zeit, sich hier zumindest zu überlegen. Ja, aber ist das eigentlich auch eine Idee für Privattoiletten, dass man in dem Moment, in dem man die Tür auf und wieder zumacht, so ein Lautsprecher in der Toilette dieses Club-Fielinger, aber nur im Badezimmer. Und dann kommen wir da raus und es ist völlige Stille. Völlige Stille.
Durchflutete Wohnzimmer, lichtdurchflutetes Wohnzimmer. Ja, um das Gefühl des Rückzugsautos zu haben. Ich glaube, das kommt richtig gut. Ich glaube auch so, da muss man arbeiten, wenn wir jetzt eh noch eine Weile nicht in Clubs gehen können. Ich bin ein Clubfieber, das ist ja klar. Ich vermisse das wie kein Zweiter. Einfach um so einen kleinen Hauch wieder zurückzuholen. Ich glaube, das würde richtig gut sein. Fände ich auch nicht so schlecht. Gute Idee. Weißt du, wie wir das nennen, die Firma? Ich habe eine Idee, aber ich... Wir nennen die das Podcast-Ufo. Das dachte ich. Das war das, was du dir auch dachtest. Ich dachte, es ist das Podcast-Ufo, ja. So nennen wir nämlich die Firma. Das finde ich richtig gut, eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt. Ja, setzt das gerne um und verkauft uns die Lizenz. Verkauft uns die Lizenz. Sowas, ja. Wir kaufen von euch die Lizenz, um unsere eigene Idee zu benutzen. Warum nicht mal disruptiv das einfach auf den Kopf stellen? Einfach das Business auch einfach mal auf den Kopf stellen. Es sind alle ein bisschen zu konstruktiv unterwegs gerade. Ja, wir müssen mehr disruptiv, wir müssen mehr aufrütteln, wir müssen zerrütten. Wir werden einfach sagen, heute ist mal ein Tag, da jagen die Verbrecher die Polizisten. So, wir gucken einfach mal, was am Ende rauskommt. Vielleicht ist es die bessere Gesellschaft.
Vielleicht haben wir einfach Sachen falschrum eingestellt.
Okay.
Oder vielleicht, dass wir heute mal sagen, heute sind alle
alle Katzen jagen Hunde.
Okay, alles klar.
Oder alle Mäuse jagen Katzen.
Wir legen uns mal wieder recht jetzt.
Oder sowas, fände ich eigentlich ganz witzig.
Oder Sachen fallen nach oben
und nicht nach unten.
Einfach mal gucken, was passiert. Du bist immer so, nein, nein, nein, aber einfach mal schauen, was passiert. Findest du nicht auch, dass Mäuse zu oft in diesem Jagder, Jäger, Gejagter Mechanismus drinstecken? Ja, man sieht wenig Mäuse privat, es stimmt schon. Die sind immer in diesem, oh, ich jag dich, nein, du jagst mich, sie jagen Mäuse, Hunde jagen sie. Du, ja, du hast ja diese klassische Kette, Hunde jagen Katzen, Katzen jagen Mäuse, Mäuse mögen Käse. Und der Käse läuft nicht weg. Käse jagt Hunde. Genau, das ist wieder Balanced. Ja. Circle of life. This is the circle of cheese. Das heißt, die Maus kann eigentlich schlecht den Käse jagen, ausser es ist eines dieser verdammten Käseräder, die einem immer davonrollen, wenn man reinbeissen will.
Stichwort Babybel, ich schau dich an, ist mir schon so oft passiert.
Wir schauen mit allen vier Augen gerade dich an, Babybel.
Babybel?
Das ist mir schon so oft passiert, dass ich die schnabulieren wollte, dann rollen die weg.
Aber es dann, anders als andere Lebensmittel, die dann irgendwie unter dem Bett vergangen oder unter der Küchenzeile, der Babybel nicht, weil das Wachs den konserviert. Irgendwann werden so alte Ägypter uns ausgraben, weil dann gibt es ja Ägypter, die sind dann wieder ein krasses Volk, graben dann uns aus und graben dann vor allem große Babybelts aus, weil die am besten konserviert sind. Ich glaube, dieser Zeitkreis fängt eh an, weil wir haben es gerade gehört, vielen Dank nochmal an Martin für das Intro, der den Piraten Sea Shanty wieder aufleben lässt. Ich finde das eh spannend, dass so auf TikTok, haben wir ja gesagt, TikTok und Sea Shanty, das passt gut zusammen, dass sich so die modernste Technologie mit uralter Technologie verbindet. Ich meine, der nächste TikTok-Hype ist irgendwie, wir bauen Pyramiden auf oder so in unserem Garten oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung oder wir machen Hieroglyphen oder ich zieh mir das Gehirn durch die Nase und dann ist man wieder von Anfang an. Ja, ich finde vor allem, man sagt immer, die 80s kommen wieder, die 90s kommen wieder, jetzt kommen die Nullerjahre zurück. Nein, lass doch mal ganz von vorne an. Wir drehen uns im Kreis seit 50 Jahren, das ist langweilig. So, wir fangen jetzt, wir lassen mal Ägypten wieder auflegen. Ja, Antike. Wann hast du das letzte Mal eine richtig schöne Phalanx gesehen? Ja. So einen schönen antiken Schildwall in der Fußgängerzone. Wir hatten es letzte Woche mit Zisternen. Ja, wo sind die denn? Da kann man mal anfangen wieder. Ja, unterirdische Wasserbehälter übrigens. Die kleine Fußnote zur letzten Folge. Jetzt bekommt das Podcast auf das Magazin. Hat uns auch jemand geschrieben, dass es ein großes Problem ist in Rom, weil Rom ist ja eine sehr historische Stadt, weil da war ja früher Rom. Da war früher Rom. Genau, und die haben ein Problem, weil wenn die eine U-Bahn bauen wollen, dann müssen die ja im Boden graben, aber die können quasi nirgendwo graben, ohne nicht irgendwelche extrem wertvollen historischen Schätzen oder Zisterne zu finden. Das heißt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es in Rom eine U-Bahn gibt oder ob man das machen kann kann, weil du immer, wenn du sagst, oh, jetzt doch ein Weinkeller wäre nett, oder, und dann stichst du einmal mit einem Spaten zack in den Woden und ding! Und sofort Cäsars Lorbeeren und so, oh, Alter, ey. Und vor allem, die haben ja einen riesigen Haufen, wo die den Müll einfach... Ja, so einen Schatzhaufen, den man kennt. Gold und Edelstein und Glitzer. Genau, den kennt man, so der Flute Karibik, kennt man den, Wenn man die Insel, die nur gefunden werden kann von Leuten, die schon wissen, wo sie liegt, da geht man rein. Und so sieht das aus, das haben die vor Rom, wo andere Städte so Müllhalten haben, wo dann so Möwen rumkreisen und Geier. Ja, in Rom hast du dann auch den goldenen Sack, extra so einen Plastiksack, wo du die ganzen Edelsteine in die Wehen reintun kannst. Den goldenen Sack, die goldene Tonne. Und dann muss man beim Nachbarn mal klingeln und fragen, kann ich deine goldene Tonne mitbenutzen, weil man ist randvoll. Ich habe im Garten wieder hier irgendwie so eine alte Truhe von Kleopatra mit lauter Probieren und Saphieren und den ganzen Schrott. Entschuldigung, was soll ich denn jetzt damit machen? Ich kann es ja nicht wieder vor die Tür stellen. Ich kriege Ärger von meinen Nachbarn. Und da muss man immer den Klüngelkerl, hieß es bei uns in meiner Heimat, wo ich herkomme, anrufen, dass der den das Sperrmüll abholt.
Da außen.
Ja?
Den Klüngelkerl. Kennst du den Klüngelkerl noch?
Nee, bei uns hat man das im Garten vergraben.
Ah, okay.
Schön die Waschmaschine, einfach Loch ausheben, rein damit und zu.
Damit einfach Archäologen in 2000 Jahren sich auch denken. Das ist die Melodie vom Klüngelkerl. Okay, Klüngelkerl. Der Klüngelkerl oder halt Schrottsammler. Und das ist eine lokale Legende oder ist das irgendeine staatliche Institution? Man hört diese Melodie, ich habe die noch nie gesehen, aber ich kenne diese Melodie, hat sie so eingebrannt in meinen Schädel, dass ich sie immer wieder rufen kann. Und das summst du und dann kommt jemand und nimmt den Schermüll weg? Das muss man dreimal summen, dann scheint er hinter dir und sagt Deine Müll bitte, eine alte Couch. Gehen Sie mit, willst du mir bei Tragen helfen? Der pfeift über so schrabbelige Lautsprecher und fährt dann auch mit so einem Pickup-Truck rum und sammelt das ein. Und wenn du was hast, dann musst du wegen ... oder dann rufst du den. Ja, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, warum man das macht mit dem Geräusch. Das muss die auch wahnsinnig machen, die da drinnen dann fahren. Und das pfeift der jedes Mal selbst, oder ist das eine Kassette? Das ist eine Kassette. A und B-Seite ist ... Das ist der gleiche Song, aber muss man manchmal wechseln, damit es... B ist Benjamin Blümchen und das muss er dann vorspulen. Das ist immer nervig. Aber Benjamin Blümchen mit seinem Tag als Schrottsammler. Das ist sehr ironisch. Nach Feierabend gönnt er sich das auch gerne mal. Interessante Figur. Vielleicht kriegen wir da mal ein Interview. Kriegen wir mal ein Interview hin. Wir sind ja momentan auch stark an unserem Interview mit einem Pornoseitenbesitzer dran. Da hat sich jemand gemeldet. Und es kann gut sein, dass ihr in der nächsten Folge aka das Podcast UFO Investigativ ein... Das Porn-Ufo. Das Porn-Ufo ein investigatives Interview mit einem echten Pornoseitenbesitzer hören könnt. Das heißt, bleibt auf jeden Fall dran. Aber mit Schattenwand, ne? Wie bitte? Mit Schattenwand.
Wir werden alle verzerrt, bis zur Unkenntlichkeit verzerrt, rauschen.
Ich werd verzerrt.
Du wirst verzerrt, ich werd auch verzerrt.
Du bist so ein bisschen Duffy, Duffy Duck, ich bin Goofy Duck.
Und wir alle einfach noch mal hardcore Wasserfall drüber,
über alles, was wir sagen, richtig harter Wasserfall.
Und so ein Club-Sound unten drunter.
Das klingt, als wäre das in so einer Club-Toilette. Das finde ich richtig gut. Die Club-Toilette finde ich übrigens einen guten Podcast. Für coolere Leute als uns fände ich die Club-Toilette einen guten Podcast. Weil dann könnten die, da könnte sogar stattfinden, weil da findet man auch schon mal, glaube ich, relativ spannende Gespräche vor. Ja. Sehr intime Sachen. Und da kommen dann immer Leute rein und Leute raus. Und du weißt immer, jetzt kommt immer Leuteues rein, wenn die Musik lauter wird und so, finde ich nicht schlecht. Was da besprochen wird auch. Ich bin auch wahrscheinlich wie du jemand, der eher in den Stall geht, in eine eigene kleine Kabine. Ja, ich habe halt einen Rucksack dabei. Du hast immer einen Rucksack dabei? Leider in meinen wenigen Club-Erlebnissen er die Garderobe missverstanden und hat er dann halt einen Rucksack an. Und was schon mal ungünstig ist. Jacke abgegeben, aber Rucksack noch auf. Wenn halt twerking on the dance floor, aber halt mit schönem Eastback. Cool. Ist schon einer der cooleren Rucksäcke, aber trotzdem in der Welt der Rucksäcke immer noch fehl am Platz einfach auf dem Dancefloor. Und wenn du getting low, getting low, halt schwer wieder hochzukommen, wenn du einen schweren Rucksack hast, wo noch dein Biologiebuch drin ist. Ja, das stimmt. Unangenehm. Von der Schule direkt in den Club auch. Absolut. Man feist sich ein bisschen, war dazwischen, gab es doch ein Fenster. Nee, nee, nee, da gab es kein Fenster. Bei mir, ich höre die Schulglocke und ich fange an zu tanzen. Okay. Ja, ich schmeiße mir was ein, ich schmeiße mir einen Schokoball ein und dann geht es raus auf Zuckerhai. Schokoball meine ich das weisse Schokoball. Oh, das kleine weisse. Vorhin zwinkert mir gerade zu, aber er hat sich glaube ich dabei einige Gesichtsmuskeln gezerrt. Oh, ich kann nichts, kannst du cool zwinkern? Hast du jemandem schon mal zugezwinkert? Also ohne jetzt als ironisch, hahaha, sondern wirklich ... Ich will jetzt keinen Namen nennen, aber Leute, die zuzwinkern, erfüllen immer auch ein bisschen dieses Player-Klischee. Also es gibt bei uns ... Also im Kollegenkreis ein paar Leute, die zwinkern, und es ist immer so ein bisschen ... weiß nicht, komisch. Es wirkt comichaft, überzeichnet. Ich kann das nicht. Das ist eine aussterbende Geste eigentlich. Habe ich jemandem ernsthaft zugezwinkert. Ach Gott, hör auf jetzt. Ich kann nur mit links zwinkern. Ja, ich auch nur. Das andere ist ein grosser, too much of an effort. Mein ganzer Kopf bewegt sich dann und mein ganzes Gesichtsschild zieht sich zusammen. Ja. Aber man kann nicht zwinkern, um den Kopf zu bewegen. Du hast auch so ein, das ist wie so, wenn man Stein wirft, man muss das Zwinkern so nach vorne werfen so ein bisschen. Du kannst dich nicht zurückziehen und dann zwingen, das funktioniert nicht. Nee. Der Körper ist dann doch sehr eingeschränkt, dafür, dass man quasi 24-7 mit dem Zeit verbringt, mit dem Körper, ist er ja dann doch ziemlich eingeschränkt. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, ich bin noch nicht aus dem Tutorial raus. Also ich habe so die fortgeschrittenen Sachen, glaube ich, noch nicht freigeschaltet. WASD bin ich noch, aber ich bin noch nicht beim Sprinten. Ich bin noch im Hauptmenü. Ich suche noch, die Lautstärke anzupassen. Ja, Grafikeinstellungen passen. Ja, aber es ist wirklich schwierig. Aber auch erst nach der Brille. Ja, ja, aber sowas wie Flickflack oder sowas, das ist wirklich fortgeschritten. Das ist ja Dreieck, Dreieck, Kreis-Start. Ist ja Flickflack, das krieg ich nicht hin. Will ich nicht hin schaffen. Kriegst du nicht hin? Nee. Verdrückst du dich zwischendurch immer oder was? Aber ich glaube, sobald ich mal ein Flickflack könnte, würde ich mich nur noch mit Flickflacks bewegen. Nur noch. Ist das eine Sitcom-Figur? Jemand so super athletisch, der dann einfach immer nur steht, oder Flickflacks, der hat keinen anderen Moment? Da hast du das Gefühl, dass manche Sachen, die man kann, manche kleinen Miniskills, die man erlernen kann, einen automatisch in so eine andere Kategorie Mensch schubsen, zum Beispiel aus dem Stand rückwärtssalto können.
Ja, vor allem man kommt auch nicht mehr zurück. Ich werde dich für den Rest seines Lebens anders sehen, wenn du aus dem Stand rückwärtssalto machst, selbst wenn du danach massiv tödlich übergewichtig wirst, für mich bist du immer noch ein anderer Mensch, für mich bist du immer noch der, der mal eine Rückwärtssalto macht. Ja, man rutscht automatisch in so eine diese Boomerang-Videos oder Instagram-Video-Ecke. Man hat auch automatisch einen Garten mit so einem grünen Rasen und dann läuft so einen cooleren modernen Musikgeschmack und springt dann diesen Rückwärtssalto. Auch der ganze Instagram-Feed besteht dann auch aus diesem Video, wie man in anderen verschiedenen coolen Klamotten, auch nur coolen Klamotten, diesen Rückwärtssalto macht. Du machst drei Flickflacks, dann Rückwärtssalto und dann fällst du so auf den Rücken und dann kommt ein Golden Retriever auf dich zu und legt dir das Gesicht ab. Das ist dein Alltag. Um eine tolle Freundin. Das passiert jeden Tag. Und dann merkt man, dass die Kamera so ein bisschen wackelt, weil die attraktive Freundin lacht. Das ist jeden Tag bei mir. Man hat auch so ein Relationship, Meme, TikTok-Account. Automatisch sofort. Deswegen, vielleicht sollte man mal sowas lernen, weil ich glaube, das ist wie die Türschwelle in eine neue, vielleicht bessere Welt. Es sind die Perks, wenn man auflevelt. Wenn du auflevelst oder eine neue Charakterklasse hast. Weil wenn du halt so in den Sports-Jog-Guy oder Popular-Guy, wenn du die Klasse auswählst, kriegst du halt einige Perks, wie halt Golden Retriever irgendwie. Aber Intelligenz minus 20. Intelligenz minus 20 ist natürlich das Problem. Obwohl das vielleicht auch nur ein böses Klischee ist, das kann man nachher wieder raussteigern. Du kannst ja, wenn du Erfahrungspunkte sammeln, dann wieder aussteigern. Ach so, weil so ein Woke-Spiel ist. Nee, weil ich glaube, das schon so funktioniert, dass ... Ich meine, du gehst natürlich durch die Welt und denkst, ah, der ist schön, der ist attraktiv. Dafür ist er nicht so schlau. Nee, vielleicht ist er schlauer als du. Er ist wahrscheinlich so schlauer als ich. Und lustiger und hat einen besseren Podcast als du. Okay, wo kann man den hören? Ja? Wo kann man den hören? Auf dieser. Dann ist er auch noch reicher als wir. Ist das nicht fair, glaube ich? Nee, das ist auch nicht fair, das stimmt schon. Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Klischee. Aber ich glaube ja auch in der Theorie, dass man nur gut in etwas wird, wenn man halt sehr viel Zeit damit verbringt. Von daher ... Was ist mit Kindern? Die sind nicht gut. Kinder, die können Flickflack, klar. Ja, aber dann können sie andere Sachen nicht. Dann können die nicht gut bei Super Mario den Endboss besiegen. Den einen Endboss Bowser. Einer heißt er. Genau, Einer heißt er. Einer. Der eine. Der eine am Ende. Der eine am Ende. Das ist auch ein Name. Wenn der Voldemort nicht, du weißt schon, wer er, sondern der eine halt. Wir sagen seinen Namen nicht. Das ist sein Name. Der eine am Ende. Das ist auch ein Name. Wenn der Voldemort nicht, du weißt schon wer, sondern der eine halt.
Wir sagen seinen Namen nicht.
Das ist sein Name.
Der eine halt.
Ich finde es immer spannend, wie ganze literarische Werke sich verändern können, wenn man nur ein Detail ändert.
Wenn man nur statt, du weißt schon wer, der eine halt gesagt hätte. Ich glaube, es wäre ein anderes Buch geworden. Ich glaube auch. Oder Harry heisst Dennis. Okayer Name. Total normaler, auch englischer Name, Dennis. Aber es ist halt Dennis Potter. Potter ist doch Krüger eigentlich, oder? Heinrich Krüger. Im Grunde in der deutschen Fassung könnte er Heinrich Krüen. Ja, oder Harald. Harald Krüger. Harald Krügler, Ronald Wiesler und Hermine Gefahr. Also da ist die noch die coolste, finde ich eigentlich. Die mit Abstand coolste. Aber Gefahr wäre auch ein guter Vorname, oder? Bellatrix die Wunderliche. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Finde ich auch gut. Neville Langboden. Das ist so etwas wie Nils Langhintern. Da merkt man dann schon, das ist merkwürdig. Ja, das ist schon eine unglückliche Figur von Anfang an. Warum hat man Beutlin eigentlich? Wer hat das da, wer hat da übersetzt, hat er mal kurz gesagt, hier verwendet mich kurz ein bisschen selbst. Beutlin? Tolkien hat auch bei der deutschen Übersetzung auch mitgeholfen. Er hat die deutsche Übersetzung gemacht. Nee, er hat nicht gemacht, aber er war da auch federführend dabei. Wirklich jetzt? Ja, das heißt, diese alte Legende von wegen ... Er hat sein No-Bullshit-Face aufgesetzt, sein Hier mache ich gerade keinen Spaß. Nee, Spaß draus. Hier weiß ich, der Spaß bleibt draussen. Es gibt ja auch diesen Mythos von wegen, dass Elben im Herr der Ringe eine Fehlübersetzung sein, eigentlich Elfen hätten heißen sollen. Nope, Tolkien selbst hat sich dafür ausgesprochen. Und ihr könnt jetzt auf ganz viele Partys zurückgehen und sagen, du, als ich dich damals beeindruckt habe mit dem Funfact, dass Elben eine Filo-Besitzung war, ich würde das gerne zurücknehmen, denn ich habe im Podcast gehört, dass das falsch ist. Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie du mit deinem wissenden Funfact-Gesicht etwas sagst, von dem ich nicht mal wusste, dass es dieses Klischee gibt. Das ist Anti-Fun-Fact. Ich bin der Fun-Fact-Basser.
Du zerstörst Fun-Facts, bevor sie überhaupt aufgetaucht sind
in meinem Leben. Ne, ne, das hört man tatsächlich oft so.
Wir haben ja auch diese ganzen Heide-Ringe-Audio-Flicks gemacht und so.
Auch ganz viele Kommentare bekommen,
Übersetzung für, ne, war einfach anders.
War einfach anders. Mir gefällt's
richtig gut, was du weißt alles.
Willst du mal den War-Einfach-Anders-Podcast
machen? Ich wollte
einmal ins Quiz-U-Boot von Super RTL. Ja, mit Commander David auch. Mit Commander David. Ich dachte kurz, weil ich eine Zeit lang hätte das geträumt, dass es diese Show gab. Nee, nee. Aber du hast es auch erlebt. Ich habe es auch erlebt. Und wir haben zu dritt drei Freunde, der Schlaue, der Freche und ich, haben wir uns dort beworben. Wir haben aus dem Internet drei Bewerbungsformulare runtergeladen, was locker vier Stunden gedauert hat, die auszudrucken. Die waren orange. Orange? Orange. Das hat auch nochmal zwei Stunden gedauert, bis der Computer orange zusammengemischt hat, da irgendwie mit seinen Falsen. Aus Magenta und Züren. Wie geht das eigentlich? Zwei Teile umrühren und dann rührte er zu viel an. Also das war ein Aufwand. Und dann hatten wir diese Bewerbungsformulare und mussten die ausfüllen. Und dann musste man da auch die Grösse angeben. Und jetzt weiß ich auch warum. Ich weiß, warum man da die Grösse angeben musste. Weil achtet mal drauf, wenn die nächste Staffel Quiz-U-Boot anläuft. Alle Kinder sind gleich gross. Alle Kinder sind exakt gleich gross. Warum? Weil die die Stühle anpassen. Ein kleines Kind kriegt einen höheren Stuhl und der Longbottom kriegt einen kürzeren Stuhl, damit die alle exakt ... Aber es ist nicht merkwürdig, weil die Proportionen sind ja trotzdem auch anders. Es ist schon merkwürdig. Und dann kommt die Aufnahmeleiterin und legt nochmal so ein Lineal über alle drei und sagt, ihr müsst exakt, du darfst dich nicht so aufrecht hinsitzen, Rebecca, du musst exakt. Und dann wird die Sendung auch abgebrochen, wenn die nicht absolut. Wenn man so ein bisschen nach vorne rückt im Stuhl. Nee, Abbruch, jetzt läuft Wasser ins U-Boot, wir brauchen Werbung. Rebecca, ich habe dir gesagt, du musst bitte so sitzen bleiben. Also das scheint die Hauptpriorität dieser Quiz-Sendung zu sein, dass alle Kinder gleich groß sind. Wahnsinn. Wahnsinn. Aber warum wie pedantisch? Weil das ist ja schon ein sehr enges Konzept mit diesem Pro-Frage-geht-s-weiter-runter-und-so, dass man dann auf diesen Effekt einbauen muss, dass alle Kinder exakt gleich groß sind, ist merkwürdig. Der nie erwähnt wird, aber einfach so wichtig von der Produktion vorgegeben ist, der hat der Geldgeber gesagt. Der Geldgeber ist ja damals auch Nachfahre von der, ja können wir sagen wie es ist, der Admiralität aus dem Dritten Reich, die die U-Boote danach vertrieben hat in die ganze Welt. Nicht nur nach Südamerika, sondern auch, kann man auch mal sagen, in verschiedene andere Länder.
Kann man sagen. Kann man so sagen. Also sich auch nicht mit Ruhm befleckt, aber die U-Boote müssen irgendwo hin. Klar. Krieg ist vorbei, du hast noch 200 U-Boote im Keller. War das so ein U-Boot-Ding, dass alle gleich groß waren? Ja, die mussten alle ihr Periskop ausgefahren, musste exakt
gleich gross. Ja, man kann sich das ja vorstellen, weil ich würde
jetzt zum Beispiel alles zerstören.
Also ich würde, nach mir müsste man
erstmal das Periskop ein bisschen runterschrauben.
Dann Echolot,
Riesenproblem.
Nee, nee, das war, Dönitz hat
gesagt, nee, egal was ihr damit macht,
es müssen alle exakt gleich gross
sein. Und der hat dann nämlich auch als Super-RTL an die Nachfahren von Dönitz getreten ist und gesagt hat, ihr habt Geld, ihr habt U-Boote an die ganze Welt verkauft, moralisch grau, trotzdem bräuchten wir Geld für unsere Quizshow. Und dann haben die gesagt, Leute, unter einer Bedingung, die Kinder müssen alle exakt gleich gross sein. Kein Spielraum. Null, nicht mal einen Millimeter. Keine Toleranzgrenze. Da muss die Maske mitarbeiten, die Frisur muss mitarbeiten, alle müssen da an einem Strang ziehen. Ich will nicht sagen, man kann dagegen arbeiten, gegen einen Zentimeter zu klein, kann man mit Frisur. Aber da ist auch wirklich, ah, scharf. Ich meine, tatsächlich ab Staffel acht, glaube ich, haben sie es so eingeführt, dass die Live-Regie die Stühle noch on the fly hoch und runter fahren konnte, sodass wenn sie gesehen haben. Auch perspektivisch, damit es perspektivisch dann passt, wenn die Kamera so leicht trägt ist. Die Kamera ist mit dem Kontrollelement der Stühle verbunden, sodass wenn die Kamera in die Perspektive schwenkt, die Stühle automatisch reagieren und die Kinder mehr oder weniger konstant hoch und runter gefahren werden. Und deswegen auch sehr schlecht waren immer. Ich habe mich immer gefragt, wieso kriegen die es nicht hin, Fragen zu beantworten. Das ist eine sehr einfache Frage. Ist Elben ein Überwachungsfehler, ja, nein, ja, nein. Da muss man also entweder A oder C oder B oder D, so sehr einfache Frage eigentlich, aber die beantworten es falsch. Warum? Weil sie die ganze Zeit von oben und unten gefahren sind. Wen schlecht ist, sie müssen sich übergeben, irgendwie ihnen wird schwindelig die ganze Zeit. Kalt, ist auch sehr kalt im Studio. Super kalt, stockdunkel, weil du bist ja 10.000 Meter unter dem Wasserspiegel. Also stockdunkel, ein Mädchen ist ohmächtig geworden während der Live-Sendung, wurde dann aber auch wieder hochgefahren, damit er liegend auf dem Stuhl noch zu sehen war. Also es war eine wilde Sendung. Wilde Sendung, aber auch passt gut in eine Reihe Fun-Facts, dessen Ursprung wir nicht mal kennen. Nee, ich weiß nicht, was du nennen, aber falls ihr beim Quiz-U-Boot mitgearbeitet habt und nicht extreme Knebelverträge unterschreiben musstet, damit ihr nicht über die Produktionsinterne redet, meldet euch gerne, vielleicht können wir euch in Verbindung bringen mit dem Pornoseitenbesitzer. Vielleicht interviewen nicht wir den Pornoseitenbesitzer, sondern Konzept, neues Konzept, ähm, nicht Moderator interviewt interessante Personen, sondern interessante Personen interviewt interessante Personen. Damit Moderator zu Hause nichts machen kann. Und sich alte Folgen vom Quiz-U-Boot angucken kann, wo er alle Antworten auswendig weiß, damit er klüger aussieht als elfjährige Kinder. Als die herumgesteuerten Kinder. U-Boot ist aber auch ein bisschen das O-Saf-Ding. Das ist einfach auch so ein deutsches Ding. Weil auch da Unterwasserboot wahrscheinlich ist da die Abkürzung, U-Boot, Unterwasserboot, oder? Ja. Unterwasserfahrboot. Ich glaube, Unterwasserboot, ja. Ja, gutes Fahren ist im Boot ja auch mit drin irgendwo. Dass man da nicht ein komplett neues Wort sich ausdenkt, oder? Idee. Submaring. Kann man nicht sagen, dass man Wörter einfach von hinten liest, wenn sie eine andere Bedeutung haben? Sprich, Überwasser, Boot, Unterwasser, Tob. Also du hast sofort Tob und jeder weiss, was ist ein Tob? Naja, das Gegenteil von Boot. Also ein Flugzeug. Das ist nicht das Gegenteil von Boot. Ja gut, da musst du uns überlegen, was genau Gegenteil bedeutet. Kann nicht schwimmen, geht unter und kann nicht schwimmen. Ein Tob ist, ich bin sehr ungern im Tob. Eine Liniensymmetrie. Alles, was über einer gewissen Linie ist, hat einen Namen und alles, was darunter ist. Zum Beispiel Maulwurf unter der Erde. Waufmaul über der Erde. Weiss ja auch jeder, dass Lava, Lava heißt, weil es über der Erde ist. Aval. Und Aval, wenn es unter der Erde ist. Das ist ja ideal. Aber so könnte man es ja theoretisch für alle anderen Recher auch machen. Wir könnten die deutsche Sprache komplett entschlacken und da komplett irgendwie ein paar Sachen rauskürzen, wenn wir das einfach vernahligender machen. Nicht immer nur Körper entschlacken, auch mal die Sprache entschlacken. Ja, wir haben so viel Schrott, da da rumliegt, so viel Quatsch. Übrigens, apropos Sprache, Intro. Sprache, Sprache, Sprache, ich zähl bis drei, nein, das sind Zahlen, sind Zahlen noch Sprache, ich glaube nicht. So, vielen Dank für dieses Intro und wir sind in unserer Kategorie die Podcast UFO Hausaufgabe. Ah, hab ich leider, ich wusste nicht, dass wir das auf heute auf hatten. Ich dachte, wir haben die 8a. Ja, vor allem bei solchen Ausreden verstehe ich immer nicht. Was machen die besser? Was macht, ich wusste nicht, dass wir die bis heute auf haben, besser als, ich hab's nicht. Ja, du hast es nicht. Das war ja wohl, die Hausaufgabe war die 8b und dann einer meiner Freunde meinte, okay, Entschuldigung, ich habe jetzt leider die 8a gemacht. Ja gut, dann liest du meine Antworten vor. Ja gut, ich habe es. Ja, besserer Versuch, weil zumindest im Prinzip, ich habe trotzdem was gemacht. Der Hund hat meine Hausaufgaben gefressen, im Prinzip ja auch trotzdem, ich habe sie ja vorher gemacht. Aber ganz kurz. Zu sagen, ich habe das nicht gemacht, weil ich dachte, wir hätten das bis morgen auf, ist ja so wie, der Hund hat mein Buch gefressen, bevor ich die Hausaufgaben machen konnte. Und danach habe ich den Prozess abgebrochen. Mein Hund hat mich gefressen, während ich Hausaufgaben gemacht habe. Und deswegen konnte ich ihn nicht machen. Ja, leider. Ganz anders natürlich die Podcast-Ufe-Community. Auf die kann man sich natürlich... Fleissig, fleissig, fleissig. Fleissig, fleissig. Einen Haufen Sterne-Schüler, einen Haufen Smiley im Heft-Schüler, Leute, die alle ihr Löschblatt dabei haben, wo man einfach weiß, ja, die tipptopp am ersten Tag nach den Ferien haben die alles dabei, alles parat, wunderbar. Beim Löschblatt hat auch kurz eine Industrie gesagt, wir packen dieses eine Blatt dazu, damit Leute kritzeln können, damit sie daraus so Papierflieger machen können, Leute können sich verwirklichen mit diesem Löschblatt. Ich stelle mir auch immer vor, dass die Löschblätter in einer anderen Fabrik hergestellt werden als die Hefte. Und dann gibt es noch mal eine dritte Fabrik, in der nur das Löschblatt in das Heft reingelegt wird. Das kriegt jeden Tag stapelweise Hefte und löschblätter geliefert. Und dann hat es eine grosse Maschine, wo es nur das Löschblatt ins Heft legt. Wie ist die Weltratio zwischen Heften und Löschblättern? Oh, eins zu eins. Ich glaube nicht eins zu eins. Ich glaube genau eins zu eins. Ich glaube nicht, jedes Heft hat ein Löschblatt. Aber jedes Löschblatt hat ein Heft. Jedes Löschblatt hat ein Heft. Manche Hefte haben zwei Löschblätter, glaube ich mal einfach. Uff! Deswegen, aber wie viel Ratio, ich glaube, es ist eher so 80, 20 pro Löschblatt. Vielleicht werden wir es nicht rausfinden, aber was wir auf jeden Fall rausfinden werden, ist, wie unglaublich fleissig die Podcast UFO Community ist, denn wir haben letzte Woche eine Hausaufgabe aufgegeben, die da lautet. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Unsere Hausaufgabe war, wir hatten Spaß daran, Worte auszusprechen. Das ist unser Job und das machen wir gerne. Wir lieben unseren Job, wir sprechen gerne Wörter aus, unter anderem haben wir gerne das Wort ausgesprochen Moloch. Moloch. Moloch. Zisterne Moloch. Tolles Wort und wir haben die Hausaufgabe an die Podcast-Ufie-Community gegeben, verwendet in dieser Woche das Wort Moloch in eurem Arbeitskontext. Darauf freue ich mich ja sehr. Und schickt uns Beispiele, wie ihr das geschafft habt. Also eine Arbeitsmail, irgendwie in einem Slack-Kanal, je nachdem, was ihr für ein Kommunikationstool verwendet, in der Rundmail das Wort Moloch verwenden. Und natürlich dachte ich erst, okay, vielleicht kommen da nicht so viele Leute, haben da nicht so viele Leute Bock drauf, aber es kam tatsächlich eine einzige Antwort. Alle anderen haben die Hausaufgabe vergessen? Alle anderen, also alle 239 Hörer haben die Hausaufgabe vergessen. Ich schau euch an. Was? Ich schau dich an Gina, ich schau dich an Jennifer, Theodor, ich schau dich an Marcel, ich schau dich an Becky, Robert, Carlos, Andra Carlos, Nadine. Wir schauen euch an, wo ist die Hausaufgabe? Ihr könnt nicht 239 Ausreden haben. Gut, hat denn der eine oder die eine, zumindest Deliver Florentin
die einzige, die ihre
Hausaufgabe fristgerecht abgegeben
hat, war, wie immer,
die Jenny.
Danke, Jenny.
Jenny, du, aber ehrlich gesagt
auch so unsympathisch, dass immer sie
die Hausaufgabe hat. Und immer noch
so eine Sonderaufgabe.
Jenny hat die Hausaufgabe gemacht und Jenny hat einen Beruf, bei dem sie Mails schreibt. Wow, was macht sie denn? Das weiß ich nicht genau. Ehrlich gesagt, hier steht die Firma, aber die möchte ich jetzt mal nicht nennen. Jenny hat einen Beruf, in dem sie Mails schreibt und sie hat eine Mail geschrieben, in dem sie das Wort Moloch benutzt. Und sie hat geschrieben, Guten Morgen, Frau Est.
Nein.
Ich nehme ins Memo-locher
Tacker, Kugelschreiber und Schreibblöcke mit.
Ins Memo-locher.
Sie hat nicht das Wort Moloch verwenden,
sie hat Memo und danach Locher geschrieben.
Jenny, das zählt nix. Jenny from the mail. Get back to the fucking block! Get back to the block! Ohne Scheiss, aber nicht so schlecht. Sie kriegt einen Kreativitäts-Smiley. Also, sie kriegt einen Kreativitäts-Smiley. Aber das ist der augenrollende Kreativitäts-Smiley. Sie hat in einer offiziellen Dienst-Mail dieses Wort einigermaßen verwendet. Ich kann ihr nicht böse sein, weil sie die Einzige ist, die die Hausaufgabe überhaupt gemacht hat. Wir wären böse, wenn sie die Einzige wäre, die sie so gemacht hat. Da kann man nicht wählerisch sein als Lehrer. Deswegen auf jeden Fall vielen Dank, Jenny. Aber da geht mehr. Ja, also nochmal. Wir geben die Hausaufgabe nochmal auf. Wir geben die jetzt so lange auf, bis jeder jeder einzelne von euch eine Lösung abgegeben hat. Es ist ja auch für die Sendung nicht so schlecht, wenn es jede Woche nur einer macht. Das ist ja okay. Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich möchte trotzdem, dass jetzt noch mehr Leute diese Aufgabe machen und auch richtig machen. Also nochmal die Ausgabe. Ihr müsst in einem beruflichen Kontext und bewiesenermaßen das Wort Moloch unterbringen. Sei es in einer Mail, sei es in einer sonstigen Textnachricht oder sei es mündlich und die müsste das Ganze dann irgendwie aufnehmen. Genau, nehmt das irgendwie auf, klar Text naheliegend, aber ich hätte auch nichts gegen so einen Anruf, der aufgenommen wird, natürlich nur eurer Seite, aber es gibt ja kreativere Lösungen, also neben es nicht zu benutzen, sondern halt mit so einem Memo-Locher und so. Man könnte ja auch, keine Ahnung, wow, hier ist schon wieder so dreckig, da hat schon wieder jemand nicht aufgeräumt, das sieht ja aus wie ein Moloch. Ja. Da würde ja niemand, also es würde kurz so einen Irritationsmoment vielleicht geben, aber niemand würde euch für bescheuert halten. Kann die Sales-Abteilung sich bitte um das Moloch in der Kaffeekirche kümmern? Genau. So was, das ist der Zettel, den will ich an der Tür von der Sales-Abteilung sehen. Kaffeemaschine haben, so, ja. So was. Das ist ein Post-it. Das ist ein Post-it. Ganz kurz für alle, die vielleicht ein bisschen mehr lernen möchten über das Wort Moloch. Und zwar Moloch ist die biblische Bezeichnung für phönizisch-kanaanäische Opferrieten, die nach der biblischen Überlieferung die Opferung von Kindern durch Feuer vorsahen. Also, have fun! Wow! Kinder durch Feuer? Ja, Kinderopfer durch Feuer. Viel Spaß damit, das war unsere Rubrik, die das Podcast-UFO-Hausaufgabe. Wie, ist es in der Kategorie Sprache die Rubrik Hausaufgabe? Ja. Hä? Jetzt machen wir erst Hausaufgabe zu, jetzt machen wir Sprache zu. Das war unsere Rubrik Sprache, Ache, Worte, Buongiorno. Jetzt sind wir wieder normal. Jetzt wieder normal. Was passiert, wenn wir jetzt nochmal zurückgehen? Das geht nicht. Wir sind immer noch enttäuscht, weil ehrlich gesagt dieser kleine Abstecher in die Rubrik ausaufgaben. Kann man über Rubriken hinaus enttäuscht sein? Nein. Alle Klammern sind zu. Du kannst innerhalb einer Rubrik in eine andere springen, solange du wieder zurückgehst. Wenn ich jetzt noch mal die Rubrik Sprache aufmache. Nein, tu es nicht. Ich frage nur, Podcaster fragen. Da fallen alle Töpfe und Schatten raus. Wir haben die gerade so zubekommen. Und wir wissen, da ist Druck auf der Tür. Und wenn wir die jetzt noch mal aufmachen, nur um reinzugucken, dann quillt da wieder Zeug drauf. Was ich jetzt noch fragen will, ist, nehmen wir dann das Gefühl wieder mit der Enttäuschung? Oder macht man es dann noch mal auf? Nee, ich würde noch mal neu anfangen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall, also jetzt die Enttäuschung bleibt. Die nehmen wir mit? Ja, das einzige, was ich aus der Rubrik Hausaufgabe mitgenommen habe, ist Enttäuschung. Okay. Über unsere Community, die wieder einen Tiefpunkt erreicht hat. Ich habe auch das Gefühl der Enttäuschung mitgenommen und ein Mawam. Gut, ich habe das Gefühl der Enttäuschung, ein Mawam und ein Pogelstick. Das Gefühl Gefühl der Enttäuschung, einen Mauerm, einen Pogostick und einen USB-Stick mitgenommen. Ich habe das Gefühl der Enttäuschung, einen Mauerm, einen Pogostick, einen USB-Stick und einen Hockey-Stick mitgenommen. Und so weiter und so weiter. So, und dann hatte ich diese Bewerbung für das Quiz-U-Boot. Oh Gott, die klammern war ja auch noch auf. Dreimal ausgedruckt, weil du hast immer ein Dreierteam gebraucht. Und drei ist eine kritische Anzahl. Ja, nicht nur für deinen Drückerpatronen. Absolut, drei ist schwierig, weil oft so ... Aber erklären wir das mal, wie diese alten Drucker, Orange, das wissen wir ja noch, weil die Klammer vor der Rubrik noch offen war.
Wie kannst du aus Zyran, warum auch immer man sich auf Gelb, Zyran und Magenta gar, gut, Magenta und Zyran, nee, Magenta und Gelb.
Klingen halt cool. Kann man Gelb nicht auch nochmal was geben oder so?
Warum ist Gelb nicht? Sun, Spirit, Dotter oder so.
Spirit, Shine, ja oder Dotter Heaven oder irgendwie sowas. Nee, Dotter finde ich weird. Ich finde aber, jetzt ganz kurz, wenn du mir das gelbste Gelb zeigen müsstest, würde ich dir ein Eigelb zeigen. Das ist in der Natur das gelbste Gelb. Jetzt sag nicht Wellensittich, ich sag, da ist ein Hauch Grün drin. Ich sag Sonnenblume. Nein. Gelbblume ist dumm, Sonnenblume ist ziemlich dumm. Jetzt gerade Osternzeit, Narzissen. Narzissen sind supergelb. Ja, Raps auch. Aber Raps ist auch ein bisschen grün mit rein. Nee, da bist du nicht. Also ich finde, Eigelb ist das gelbste Gelb. Aber das kann man bestimmt wissenschaftlich festlegen, was das gelbste Gelb ist, oder? Ja, schwierig. Ist das nicht auch ein bisschen objektiv, weil ich weiß nicht genau, ob man den Gelbwert messen kann. Naja, du musst einfach alle Gelbstehen. Ich kann mal literally den Gelbwert messen. Jeder Gelb ist ja eine gewisse Wellenlänge von Licht. Und dann nimmst du einfach das, was genau in der Mitte liegt von allen Gelben, Gelbs. Wenn Wellenlängen, wenn Licht Wellenlängen sind und Töne Wellenlängen. Du kannst noch umdrehen, ne? Du kannst jetzt noch umdrehen. Ich bin, ich renne sogar in eine Richtung gerade und ich gucke mich nicht mehr um. Blinker, kein Blinker. Du hast eine Ausfahrt, da kommt eine Ausfahrt. Kann man da nicht Gemälden, ein Geräusch geben? Nein, aber eine perfekte Ausfahrt. Also du willst Farben in Ton umrechnen, oder was? Oder umgekehrt. Ich will mal wissen, wie sieht denn Beethovens Fünfte aus? Ich will aber auch wissen, wie klingt die Mona Lisa? Ja. Und vielleicht hat irgendwie Leonardo da Vinci irgendwo so eine, meinte mal wieder clever sein zu müssen, und hat irgendwo so eine versteckte Botschaft eingebaut oder sowas. Und das einfach so groß, Buongiorno! Einfach ganz laut so geschrien, die Mona Lisa. Damals waren die Aufnahmemethoden aber auch nicht so gut, da musste man auch. Buongiorno! Einfach so, hätte er so eine höhere Stimme auch gehabt. Ja. Ja, ich weiss es nicht. Ich stelle nur Fragen. Ihr müsst wie immer nicht antworten, aber könnt ihr so diese B-Hausaufgabe machen. Kriegt man bestimmt hin. Rechne das mal um. Aber ich glaube, da kannst du einfach alles, was gelb ist, nehmen und in die Mitte nehmen. Das ist das gelbste Gelb. Sehr gut. Finde ich gut. Ich habe heute ein ganz tolles Video gesehen von meinem Lieblings-Youtuber Adam Neely. Ah, Neely! Neely über eine Analyse der Interpretation von Lady Gagas Star-Sprangled Banner in der Inauguration. Genau, von beiden. Jetzt nochmal auf Deutsch. Lady Gaga hat nämlich die US-Hymne gesungen, die Nationalhymne der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika, bei der Amtseinführung von Biden. Und das war wirklich sehr interessant und ich habe in dem Moment auch Gänsehaut gehabt, als sie gesagt hat, our flag was still there, und dann hat man quasi die ganzen Flaggen gesehen, die repräsentativ da standen für die ganzen Opfer von Covid. Und so, und es hat musikalisch unfassbar
einem in die Magen grubend,
Magen grubend,
in die Magen gehauen.
Und man hat sich gefragt, warum eigentlich,
was passiert ihr eigentlich gerade musikalisch?
Sie wechselt vom Vierteltakt in den Dreivierteltakt,
und das bei einer Hymne, das bei einer Popkünstlerin, wo man ja sagt, das ist ja wahrscheinlich eher einfacher gestrickt oder sowas, musikalisch. Nein, superkomplex, supercrazy. Das würde jetzt natürlich in Farben, würde das dem Wechsel von einem Blauton in ein helles Zyran entsprechen. Also es ist nicht viel, aber es ist schon, man merkt es. Da passiert ein bisschen was. Da passiert auf jeden Fall ein bisschen was. So ein gepunktetes Zyran. Aber jetzt müssen wir eigentlich die Klammer zumachen, weil wenn du jetzt ein Musikvideo empfiehlst, Adam Milly mit Lady Gaga, empfehle ich ein Farbvideo. Es gibt nämlich ein tolles Video über, dass die Farbe braun nicht existiert. So, und den Rest findet ihr auf Google. Du kannst mir Pluto nehmen, du kannst mir schwarz nehmen, du kannst mir Weiß keine Farbe, Schwarz ist keine Farbe, nervt eh schon immer. Der Daumen ist kein Finger. Der Daumen ist kein Finger. Erdbeeren sind Nüsse. Nein! Words have meanings. Nein, Braun ist keine Farbe, sorry. Braun ist eine Farbe. Es tut mir leid, du hast lange genug in dieser Welt gelebt, um einen Halt zu haben, an dem du dich jetzt festhalten kannst, denn ich bin bereit, dir diesen Teppich unter den Füßen wegzuziehen.
Braun ist keine Farbe, Braun existiert nicht, Braun ist nämlich nur dunkles Orange.
Gut, dann existiert Blau auch nicht.
Blau ist nur ein rötliches...
Nee, nee, nee, rötlich zählt nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Schaut es euch an, weil, schaut euch das Video an, einfach auf YouTube eingeben, Braun ist not a color oder sowas findet ihr schon, denn du kannst dir zum Beispiel auch so, also stell dir so ein Neonlicht vor, so ein Neonschriftzug mit Licht, also Licht, das farbig ist, okay? Ach so. Buntes Licht. Okay. Rotes Licht, gelbes Licht. Es gibt kein braunes Licht. Du kannst nicht sagen, wir von unserer Firma, das Podcast UFO, wollen ein braunes Leuchtschild haben.
Braunes Neon. Von unserem Headquarters. Dann sagt der Lichttechniker, sagt, es tut mir wirklich leid, Herr Vorstandsvorsitzender Tietze, das geht nicht. So, also eine Farbempfehlung und eine Musikempfehlung. Moment kurz, Moment kurz, Moment, ganz langsam. Wir nehmen mal ein paar PS runter raus. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir müssen umdrehen. Wir haben schon seit drei Minuten so diesen Lakitu über uns in der Wolke schweben, der uns zeigt, du fährst auf die falsche Richtung. Wir schalten mal einen Gang runter, hier ist jetzt Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung mal kurz. Langsam. Kurz mal Kinderstrasse gerade. Also, wenn ich jetzt so ein, ich sag mal den lustigen Poop-Emoji, den Kackhaufen-Emoji nehme. Du meinst den dunklen Orangen? Den braunen, brauneste Farbe, Team brauneste Farbe, Hashtag brauneste Farbe, farbigen Emoji. Jetzt stellt man sich den vor als dieses, als so ein
Emoji-Nachtlicht.
Ja. Gibt es wahrscheinlich auch von diesem
lustigen Tränen-Lachaugen-Emoji
als Nachtlicht. Einfach
vorne das Symbol, so eine halbtransparente Folie,
dahinter Lichtquelle.
Du willst mir sagen, dass dieses braune
Emoji, was von hinten
Licht bekommt, nicht
braunes Licht gibt, wie alle anderen Farben, die es auch gibt auf der Welt? Es gibt dunkel oranges Licht, kein braunes Licht. Und das Tolle ist, und das werdet ihr in dem Video sehen, Stefan, das werdet ihr in dem Video sehen, ist das Kontextabhängig. Ist orange nicht nur dunkel gelb? Das ist meine Frage. Gibt es nicht orange auch nicht, weil es auch genau die Mitte zwischen rot und gelb ist? Du nimmst folgendes Vorschlag. Du rühst es an allen Farben. Ich will folgendes Vorschlag. Stefan, du hast einen hochrunden Kopf. Ja. Du bist wirklich stehend. Nee, nügelgelb. Du trommelst gegen die Wand. Ich würde sagen, wir beruhigen uns alle gerade mal ein bisschen. Gehen wir mal kurz in die Spielstrasse, verkehrsberückte Zone, gerade an Zebrastreifen, und warten einfach mal die Woche ab. Und du schaust dir das Video an, und ich schaue mir das Video auch noch mal an, und ihr da draußen, die jetzt auch schon in die Tasten hackt und irgendwie Hashtag Braun ist ne Farbe schreibt, wir schauen uns alle das Video an. Hashtag Braun ist ne Farbe. Wir schauen uns alle das Video an, ihr könnt ja darunter kommentieren, die Podcast UFO Crew, Hashtag Braun ist ne Farbe, wir schauen uns das Video alle an und nächste Woche treffen wir uns zum gleichen Zeitpunkt wieder hier und diskutieren das aus, okay? Du möchtest mir sagen, bevor ich die Bewegung Braunes in Farbe starte, soll ich mir erstmal den Auslöser für das Video einstellen. Nein, das ist ja jetzt schon geschehen. Du hast die Petition ja schon ausgeschickt. Das meine ich. Das Stadion ist ja schon voll. Du hast ja schon die Leute eingesammelt. Es geht zu schnell mittlerweile. Ja, es ist zu schnell. Du hast die Petition ja schon eingereicht am Bundestag und die müssen sich damit beschäftigen. Hashtag Braunes in Farbe. Hashtag Pluto is the planet. Und denkst du wieder Hashtag sorry für den Hashtag von letzter Woche. Der ist der einzige, der bei dir gnadenlos trendet. So, also, wir hatten also die orangen Formulare ausgedruckt, nach langem Hin und Her und hatten jetzt die Möglichkeit, endlich beim Quiz U-Boot mitzumachen. Und du denkst jetzt natürlich, ein Team aus drei Leuten. Ich bin amazed, dass diese Klammer noch offen ist und Und du noch weißt, dass sie offen ist. Und jetzt ist natürlich immer so drei Leute. Wer kommt ins Fonds? War die denn gleich groß oder hätten die ordentlich rummanövrieren müssen? Tatsächlich war der Schlauste der Kleinste. Zufall? Ich glaube ja. Und dann haben wir uns zusammengetan. Und drei ist, finde ich, immer so ... Keine Zahl.
Ja, ich wollte es gerade sagen.
Drei ist keine Zahl, weil drei existiert nicht.
Achtung, denkt an Menschen.
Denkt an Menschen.
Die Gruppe von drei Menschen existiert nicht.
Es ist immer entweder zwei plus eins oder vier minus eins.
Aber es ist nie drei.
Wir machen diese Woche das Video, drei ist keine Zahl.
Weil drei ist nur eine Zahl plus eins. Vier ist eine Zahl. Ja, vier ist eine Zahl und dann kannst du vier minus eins sagen, aber drei ist keine Zahl. Braun ist keine Farbe und drei ist keine Zahl, beziehungsweise wenn Braun keine Farbe ist, dann ist drei auch keine Zahl. Und Fiss ist kein fucking Ton. Okay, jetzt wird er aufgeräumt hier. Nee, aber es ist tatsächlich, drei ist keine Zahl. Du hast entweder zwei Leute, die noch einen brauchen, oder du hast eine Vierergruppe, die einen zu Hause lassen müssen. Kein Freundeskreis ist drei Leute groß. Ich war immer in Freundeskreisen mit drei Leuten und ich hab mich, es ist immer scheiße, es gibt immer einem Kacke. Auch beim Sleepover.
Einer kriegt die Kackmatratze.
Oder einer ist immer unwillkommen.
Zwei Reden, du kannst dich zu dritt reden.
Du kannst dich nicht zu dritt küssen.
Das ist auch noch offen. Ich will nicht sagen, dass sich Hörer gemeldet haben,
um mir dieses Erlebnis zu bieten,
dass da ein bisschen auch was unter der Ladentheke geschiehtieht hier bei Podcast UFO. Vielleicht würde es ein grosses Event geben. Ein Kuss-Event? Ich will nicht spoilern, aber dieser Sommer wird heiß. Ich glaube nicht, dass der Sommer ... Heiss und unangenehm. Der Sommer wird heiß. Heiss und schwül. Aber drei ist keine Zahl. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Und so war es natürlich auch bei uns. Und um ehrlich zu sagen, ich war die drei. Ich war die drei, es waren zwei Kluge, die sich zusammengetan haben. Und ich war halt auch im Freundeskreis und die haben gesagt, hättest du noch Zeit, weil wir brauchen drei und die haben mich mal mitgenommen. Ich bin nicht stolz drauf, aber so ist es. Nischiger Witz, wenn drei keine Zahl ist und braun keine Farbe, was macht dann Diktri? Okay, Diktri, das Telefon klingelt seit einer Stunde durch, Diktri ist völlig mit den Nerven am Ende. Diktri, mit allen drei Köpfen oder zwei plus eins Köpfen, mit allen dunkelorangen zwei plus einen Köpfen, schreien sie in den Hörer. Ja. D Diktry ist außer sich. Es existiert nämlich dann nicht. Diktry existiert nicht. Das ist meine Bewegung. Vor allem, wenn Diktry unter der Erde ist, ist es Driedick. Driedick fährt im Tob unter Wasser. Zwanzig verpasste Anrufe? Was zur Hölle ist hier los? Diktry ist gecancelt. Diktry ist fucking gecancelt. Diktry existiert nicht. Das ist der neue Hashtag. Und ja, das war dann so, sie haben mich gebraucht noch für ihr Team und ich war dabei, aber ich habe mich nicht so wohl gefühlt, weil ich war damals noch nicht so schlau wie heute vielleicht.
Heute weiß ich das mit Tolkien
und der Übersetzung von
der Helleringe. Damals wusste ich das noch nicht,
da war ich noch nicht so schlau und wir haben das
ausgeführt und da muss man natürlich dann so ein Formular ausfüllen
wie, was sind deine Hobbys, also die
wollen schon mal gucken, so du brauchst bei einer Quizshow natürlich auch
Leute, die interessant sind, da brauchst du das nicht irgendwie
ich mag keinen Spinat,
nee, ja, lame.
Ich glaube nicht, dass beim Unterwasser Quiz-U-Brot
spannende Leute waren, das waren nicht die
Die Leute, die interessant sind. Da brauchst du das nicht irgendwie ich mag keinen Spinat, nee, ja, lame. Ich glaube nicht, dass beim Unterwasser-Quiz-U-Brot spannende Leute waren, das war nicht die Idee. Naja, aber das ist natürlich schwer, auch die interessante Kette zu finden. Das ist die knallharteste Casting-Agentur. Ja? Wir brauchen Leute, die exakt gleich groß sind, interessant sind und spannend in unserem sehr nischigen Unterwasser-Quiz-Format funktionieren, sehr lange die Luft anhalten können. Vor allem ist es schwer, also das werden wahrscheinlich viele Leute wissen, die sich für Jobs bewerben, viele oder so, es ist schwer, in einem Fragebogen interessant zu wirken. Weil es ist schwer. Naja, ich spiel Unke immer auf die Fenster, wo du ein bisschen mehr Textnotizen und dann ist es nur 50 Zeichen. Und die gar nicht übertragen werden. Liesst die gar nicht durch. Ich weiß noch, dass... Jaja. Auf jeden Fall haben wir dann die Formulare abgeschickt und lange gewartet und haben eigentlich schon gewartet, wann kommt unsere Folge. Wir haben wieder die Folge geguckt und dachten uns, wann sind wir endlich im Fernsehen. Ihr wart da? Nee, nee, wir haben nur im Fernsehen geguckt und dachten uns, wann sehen wir uns selbst so. Wann sind wir im Fernsehen? Und wir waren nie im Fernsehen. Ach so, ihr wart einfach nie da?
Ne, wir haben uns beworben, wurden nicht
genommen und haben die Sendung trotzdem gerne.
Klar, natürlich guck mal, das sind gerne. Ich habe mich auch
bei Commander David beworben, also war wahrscheinlich
unser beider Held dann damals, Zufall.
Auch mit plus zwei oder was?
Ja, wir waren eins plus zwei, aber für
den Super-Toll-Club.
Ja, weil es da mehr zu gewinnen gab oder weil ihr nicht so schlau wart? Weil es da mehr zu gewinnen gab und wir nicht so schlau waren. Ja. Aber schlau genug, um zu wissen, dass es da mehr zu gewinnen gibt. Das haben wir nicht geschafft. Kommando David. Was macht der heutzutage? Ist der Commodore David? Commodore David! Commodore! Ist der befördert worden mittlerweile? Ich weiß es, ehrlich gesagt. Keine Ahnung, was da passiert ist. Der leitet heute die Space Force oder irgendwie sowas. Die Space Force der deutschen Bundeswehr. Die haben so ein kleines Büro. Das wäre so hilarious. General David. Aber guck mal, das ist doch auch ein Sketch, oder? General David, den kriegt man bestimmt, den Typen irgendwie. Und dann macht man so bei der Bundeswehr so ein Ecken, ganz kleines Büro in der Ecke, die Space Force der Bundeswehr, die dann so in den Himmel gucken und dann sagt, oh, die Venus. Und dann schießt er so mit seiner Walter auf die Venus. Nimm das! Mit der Flack, auf die Venus einfach. Mach auch Scheiss! Ja, fuck it! Mach auch Scheiss auf den Mars schießen. Das ist doch jetzt mal so eine Schlagzeile, die wir brauchen. Venus besiegt. Wir haben endlich die Venus besiegt. Die Venus ist auf die Sonne gefallen. Ja, um 18.04 deutscher Zeit hat eine Tomahawk-Rakete die Venus erfasst und vernichtet. Hussah, Hur hurra, endlich wieder Frieden. Feierabend mit Venus. Endlich ist wieder Frieden im Universum. Ein Problem weniger. Das wäre mal eine Nachricht, da würde ich mich freuen. Aber nein, glaubst du, da würden so Umweltschutzvereine kommen? Weil die Venus ist ja ein superfeindlicher Planet. Gaswolken stechen dir die Augen aus. Das ist ja furchtbar. Also alles, wofür Umweltvereine hier kämpfen, würde da sterben. Das ist eigentlich der unnatürlichste, furchtbarste Planet. Wenn wir jetzt die Venus besiegen würden. Ich glaube, Peter ist in der ersten Reihe. Ich glaube, Peter werfen Speere oder so. Auf die Venus oder auf uns?
Nee, auf die Venus.
Die sagen Fuck Venus.
Würde irgendwer für die Venus denn kämpfen?
Puh, Milan vielleicht?
Die Leute irgendwie, ich weiss nicht, was die Milana heute so machen, dass die nochmal sagen, ey, wieso das denn?
Die Milano-Mens?
Obwohl, die sagen eigentlich, die müssten eigentlich sagen, weg mit der Venus, damit die mehr Suchanfragen kriegen.
Die Venus von Milan, dieses Gemälde.
Weil die, wenn du googelst nach Venus, kriegst du ja wahrscheinlich oft den Planeten.
Und die sagen, wenn der Planet weg ist, kriegen wir mehr Suchanfragen.
Das macht Sinn. Das macht auf jeden Fall Sinn.
Absolut Sinn.
Venus, Liebesgottin, ne?
Ja, Schönheit und so was.
Ich glaube nämlich, dass deswegen, dann würdenleser ... ... innen sauer werden. Gut, aber ist das eine ... eine Feindesgruppe, vor der man wirklich Angst haben muss? Affront, wir kriegen einen riesen Shitstorm von Handleser. Sie haben das Meeting eingefordert. Ich dachte mir, wir können da kurz noch mal alles auf den Tisch legen, bevor wir die Venus abschießen.
Weil hier immer noch die Frage, warum.
Nein, also wir haben durchgegangen.
Wer könnte uns das erklären? Mormonen? Nein.
Sämtliche Religionen sind auf unserer Seite.
Wir haben alle, die sagen, alle Erde ist Gott geschafft und es ist eh der beste Planet.
Huhuhu, die Erde cool.
Also es ist eh gegen die Venus. Das einzige
ist ein kleines Dorf in Milan.
Tut sich ein bisschen schwer mit der Übersetzung.
Aber das sind, glaube ich,
eine Sprachhürden, die können wir überkommen.
Allerdings
uns hat
ein Rabe erreicht.
Ein Rabe?
Ja.
Ein Rabe hat uns erreicht.
Er trug eine Papierrolle im Schnabel. die verkündet hat von dem Zorn einer bestimmten Menschengruppe, die wir verärgert haben.
Es sind die Handleser. Die Handleser haben uns den Krieg erklärt, sie haben uns in ein Ultimatum gestellt, wir sollen bis morgen früh die Kampfhandlungen gegen die Venus einstellen, ansonsten werden sie aktiv. Oho, wow, was machen sie dann? Lesen sie meine Hand und sagen, ich werde bald sterben? Sie haben gesagt, das haben wir nicht kommen sehen, aber so wie es jetzt läuft, müssen wir eingreifen. Das haben sie nicht kommen sehen. Sie wurden völlig überrascht. Sie wurden in der Zukunft quasi komplett überrascht. Sie wurden von unserem Angriff auf die Venus völlig auf dem falschen Fuß erwischt. Völlig auf der falschen Hand erwischt. Wissen Sie was, Commodore? Schießen Sie. Sind Sie sich wirklich sicher? Schießen Sie. Können Sie dieses Opfer wirklich verkraften? Schießenessen Sie die Venus an or the sky! Das dauerte sechseinhalb Jahre, bis die Rakete, da Venus ist. Ach so. Also, wir können noch ... Wollen wir das bestellen? Ja. Indisch? Ja, gut. Zwei Nan? Ja, gern Garlik-Nan und ... Ein Garlik und ein Normal? Nee, gern zwei Garlik-Nan. Zwei-G? Ja, gerne Garliknan und ... Ein Garlik und ein normal? Nee, gerne zwei Garliknanen. Zwei Garliknanen. Ja. Und Butterchicken. Frank, möchtest du auch noch Wasser? Weil wir ja hier essen wollen, vielleicht können wir nur einen Garliknanen pro Person. Weil ... Also, nee, ne zwei. Ja, weil, warum nicht so? Also, ich verstehe, ich lebe es natürlich auch lieber Gararlignan. Aber immer diese Bedenken, jeden Mittag, nee, komm, zwei Garlignan, ich bezeile auch selber. Die Sache ist, wenn Sie jetzt anfangen, zwei Garlignans zu essen, kommen irgendwann auch die ganzen anderen Offiziere, die generell und Admirate. Ich muss es ja nicht sagen, ich kann es auch privat sagen. Ich muss es ja nicht sagen, es ist ja so, also, ohne Ihnen zu nahe zu treten, man riecht es ja auch, wenn Sie zwei Gallignans verzehrt haben. Dann essen Sie auch Gallignan. Ja, aber das ändert das Problem nicht. Sehen Sie, das ist eine Kettenreaktion. Wenn ich jetzt auch anfange, zwei Gallignans zu essen, dann gehen wir raus zu den Gallignan und die merken, oh, die verzehren zwei Gallignans. Die verzehren gerade. Die sich gerade zurückhalten mit den Gallignans, die normalen Nans bestellen. Dann fangen die auch irgendwann an, Galignans zu bestellen. Das ist genau das Duckmäusertum. Das ist Duckmäusertum. Ich möchte einfach nur vor einer drohenden Katastrophe warnen, dass das eine Kettenreaktion ist, die wir vielleicht irgendwann nicht mehr aufhalten können. Commodore, ich befehle Ihnen jetzt, Galignans für mich zu bestellen. Wieder mild? Ja. Kleine Randnotiz an der Stelle, du hast ja angesprochen, gibt es eine Tierschutzorganisation, die sich kümmert um, äh, über eine Planetenschutzorganisation. Ich habe dir letzte Woche auch gesagt, was ist eigentlich mit der Computerschutzorganisation, denn ich habe mich selber angezeigt, ich habe gesagt, ich gehe schlecht mit meinem Laptop um. Oh, ich sehe gerade wieder ... Aha! Mir fällt gerade auf, mir hellem Geist fällt gerade auf, dass du gar keine Maus mehr dran hast. Richtig, letzte Woche waren nämlich mein Trackpad und meine Tastatur kaputt und ich musste hier mit so einer dummen, ollen Aldi-Maus hier antanzen und es war demütigend. Und ich habe mir aber schön ein Ersatzteil bestellt, Laptop aufgeschraubt, ausgetauscht und neu bestellt. Hast du denn diese Druckluftpistole auch gehabt? Nein, ich hatte keine Druckluftpistole, ich habe bis zum Ende mit mir herumgeharrt. Falsches Wort auch, ja. Das war verrückte Nachtpfer, schießt auf seinen Laptop. Und ich habe dann aber allerdings, sag ich mal, die menschengemachte Druckluft benutzt und ich habe reingepustet in meinen offenen Laptop. Und es war ein Heidenspaß, es war ein Heidenspaß, da den ganzen Staub rauszupusten. War viel Staub drin? War viel Staub drin. Wie kommt er da rein? Naja, durch die ganzen Ritzen, durch die Lüftung! Durch die Lüftung! Da musste ja Luft rein. Und in der Luft ist Staub. Und das Tolle war, es gab unterschiedliche Grössen von Staub. Es gab einmal den fluffigen, den festen Staub, irgendwo in den Schaltkreisen, aber in dem Ventilator war noch mal ganz feiner Staub. Das war so, mhm, das war so der feinste Staub, den man überhaupt nur haben kann. So ganz fein, wirklich so staubiger Staub. Stellt euch Staub vor, aber noch staubiger. Ich habe es mir, glaube ich, vorgestellt. Mega. Und das habe ich benutzt mit einem Strohalm. Ja, ich weiß, jeder hat zu Hause noch ein paar Strohalme rumliegen. Einen? Man schämt sich für die Strohalme, man weiß, das ist nicht mehr in Ordnung. Die EU hat die Strohalme verboten, jeder hat noch ein paar im Keller rumliegen und man weiß, ich werde die irgendwann vernichten müssen. Die nächste Grillparty kommt bestimmt, kann ich sie noch nehmen. Ja. Ich habe sie immer gekauft. Ja, jetzt, der Schaden ist angerichtet. Der Schaden ist bereits angerichtet. Es ist schwierig und ich habe sogar vorhin den so ein bisschen zusammengeknüllt, um die Öffnung weiter zu verengen. Da habe ich dir gesagt, da musst du vorsichtig sein. Ja, aber es hat funktioniert. Also es hat grossen, grossen Spaß gemacht. Und mit einem kleinen Kabel, das ich für 10 Euro bestellt habe, das Flexkabel, also falls ihr das Problem auch habt, wenn euer MacBook Pro, die Tastatur und das Trackpad, beides nicht mehr geht, dann liegt es am Flexkabel. Bestellt das und habt einen Schmachstel. Heute werden die wichtigen Probleme angesprochen. Ich finde, man darf auch nicht nur kaputt machen, man muss auch Dinge aufbauen. Okay, also vor dieses Live-Fact für die Woche ist das Flexkabel, falls bei eurem MacBook Pro ihr privilegierten Arschlöcher da draußen, Trackpad und man hat nicht funktionieren. Wir haben heute vieles eingerissen, wir haben viele in Fragen gestellt, aber ich finde, wir haben auch was aufgebaut. Und sehr wenig wieder errichtet. Ja, sehr wenig konstruktiv. Vielen Dank nochmal an Jenny, die als einzige die Hausaufgabe abgegeben hat. Vielen Dank, Jenny. Wir gucken alle anderen mal wieder an.
Ich erwarte von euch, dass ihr die Hausaufgabe macht.
Einfach bei uns in unser Fach.
Einfach legen. Zentrale-podcast-ufo.fail.
Schickt uns eure Hausaufgabe und wir wollen auf jeden Fall nächste Woche mindestens zwei haben.
Bis dahin sagen wir Tschüss, schöne Woche und wir heben ab.